Let me just wrap up by doing a couple quick things. Earlier
on when we were talking, you made a kind of offhand comment about,
or maybe I made an offhand comment, about the fact that because we're
doing this little prisoners dilemma thing, we have this sort of wall here,
we're going to end up in this little bad place. Right? With
the -6, -6. And there was this kind of notion that what if
we could hear each other, would that make a difference? And the answer
was, no not really, because who ever goes first is going to lose.
And if you try to get people to go at the
same time, well in some sense, that's the same thing as having
a wall and you can't hear each other if you have
to go at exactly the same time. Right, does that make sense?
>> I didn't quite understand. Why does the first, person who goes first lose?
>> Because if I find out whether you're going to cooperate or
defect, then I will just then do the thing that makes sense.
So if you do anything but defect, I will defect, and
then I will win and you will lose. So whoever goes first
runs the risk of the other person screwing them over. So.
>> I see. Unless, unless that person defects.
>> Right, but if that person defects, the other person's going to defect.
>> Right, so, but you don't lose any more than you would have.
>> That's true, and, but you still end up in this kind of
unfortunate place. So, one question you might
have there is, yeah, but that's just
because you can only do this once. But what if you could do this
twice? So, let's imagine were, going to be in this situation today and then were
going to be in this situation tomorrow because, you
know, you keep leading me astray. So, whatever happens today
I can use as information, for what I might
do tomorrow. So, if I decide to go ahead and
cooperate this time. And you defect, and I know
you're the kind of person who defects, and so when
we're in this situation again, I am definitely going to
defect. So maybe in that situation, it's in your best
interest to go ahead and cooperate
because, then we can keep coopoerating together,
and in the end it sort of works out. So maybe this notion
of not just playing prisoners' dilemma
once, But playing prisoner's dilemma twice or
three times, or four times, or five times, might come to a different result.
>> Yeah, that seems plausible. I mean, I could
imagine saying to you though this channel in the
wall, something that says, you know, cooperate with me
or, yeah, right, or I will, I will stop cooperating
with you. And so, you get more reward if you, if you cooperate with me.
>> Right. So, my question to you is,
what does happen exactly in this set? Where
I have two versions, two consecutive games of
prisoner's dilemma to play. What am I going to do?
>> Ok, well now I mean, we could turn this into a
game, right? I mean, that's what you were teaching us how to do.
>> Yeah.
>> So you, so now the game has four,
well, I don't know. So one way to do it is
to say A has a choice to make on the first
step, and [COUGH] that could be cooperate or defect, and then
the second step could be cooperate or defect, so there's four possibilities.
>> Right.
>> B has the same four possibilities. But maybe we can actually
have A be responsive to B. So A has two things to
do on the first step and then two things to do on
the second step for each thing that B did on the first
step, for a total of eight combinations.
>> Right. You could do that. [CROSSTALK]
>> So if we made an eight by eight matrix, we should be able to solve it.
>> Right. So, that's pretty easy to do.
You just kind of draw an eight by eight
matrix in, you know, that many dimensions. And
it, you know, you end up right here.
>> I wasn't thinking about that many dimensions. I
just thought, like the normal kind of matrix. But, okay.
>> Oh, I see, I see, I see.
>> I mean its eight by eight, so that's kind
of a pain. Right. So, its 64 cells and, I guess,
I guess we don't want to fill that out.
>> Yeah, but you know. We could fill that out. But, I'm going to help
you out here by pointing out You know what? It's not going to make a difference.
>> Oh.
>> So, here. Let's see if I can walk
you through why it's not going to make a difference.